in 2003 nobel laureate vitaly ginsberg
said that there are a number of holy
grails left to be discovered in physics
that
if found would revolutionize our
understanding of the world we live in
now his list included all kinds of
exotic phenomena and technologies like
dark matter detection and controlled
nuclear fusion
but unfortunately most of these have
we've yet to find
but 2020 might finally have produced
some good news because
according to a paper that just came out
in nature a team of physicists
just discovered number two on ginsburg's
list
room temperature superconductors now
this
is incredibly exciting because room
temperature superconductors
are a technology that if we can find a
way to mass produce them
will revolutionize energy efficiency and
transform electronics across the board
and i'm here at
the university of rochester where this
discovery has been
found to interview the two scientists
behind it
dr ashken salamat and dr ranga diaz
so stay tuned for an exclusive insight
into this groundbreaking discovery
but first what exactly is a
superconductor and
why is a room temperature one so
important well it all comes down to
energy and heat when we talk about
electricity
what we're really talking about is the
flow of electrons through a material
like a wire from point a
to point b but it's not always that easy
for these electrons to flow because
they're
constantly interacting with atoms within
that wire along the way
and all these interactions create a kind
of internal friction known as electrical
resistance
and kind of like how your hands get hot
when you rub them together due to
friction
this electrical resistance creates a
load of waste heat
too which is why things like phones and
laptops often overheat if you use them
too much
and all this waste heat really adds up
in fact it's estimated that between five
to ten percent of
all the electricity we send down the
grid gets wasted by it
and that adds up to cost of around 20
billion dollars
per year in the us alone now back in
1911
a dutch physicist discovered something
astonishing
he was playing around with the metal
mercury to see how its resistance would
behave
at really cold temperatures he reasoned
that
because resistance is caused by
vibrating atoms
and atoms vibrate because of heat energy
then if you made the metal colder its
resistance should gradually decrease too
down to some finite value
but instead of doing that suddenly at
just 4.2 degrees above absolute zero the
mercury's internal resistance
disappeared entirely for some strange
reason
below that critical temperature the
mercury became a literal
perfect conductor to the point that if
you put a current through it it would
keep flowing forever
and ever like some kind of perpetual
motion machine
he called this bizarre phenomenon
superconductivity and in fact won the
nobel prize for it two years later
and since then we've discovered a number
of different superconducting materials
which we use in
many kinds of cutting-edge tech like mri
machines
particle accelerators even fusion
reactors
we even use them to levitate stuff
thanks to a thing known as the meissner
effect
where a magnetic field is expelled so
strongly outside of the superconductor
it can even levitate trains
so yeah superconductors are pretty much
the coolest thing ever
and therein lies the problem because
unfortunately all the ones we're
currently using
require extremely cold temperatures to
maintain
which means they use a lot of energy in
fact that's one of the reasons why mri
scans cost so much because
they need all this liquid helium which
is a resource we are rapidly running out
of
to keep them cool at four degrees kelvin
just a smidge above absolute zero and
even though tons of headway has been
made in the quest for a room temperature
one
still the best we've achieved so far is
-23 degrees
celsius so still well below freezing and
when you consider that still today
over 60 percent of our electricity comes
from climate change causing fossil fuels
you can see why this is a holy grail of
physics
so on that note let's meet the two
physicists who have finally found one
can you tell me what it is exactly that
you've found
we have engineered a new material which
we call it carbonaceous sulfur hydride
it has carbon and a sulfur and hydrogen
it's a room temperature superconductor
which never existed on earth before
the superconductor at 15 degrees celsius
so explain to me
what it is that you guys have done
differently our scientific speciality
is actually exploring materials under
very high pressure conditions
we use something called a diamond anvil
cell this is a handheld device
that utilizes the optical mechanical
properties of diamond
and really what it is is a search engine
for exploring compositional face space
we can throw a bunch of materials into
our little handheld device
and we can modulate pressure as well as
temperature
and it allows us to look for materials
that mother nature herself isn't very
good at making or in fact can't even
make
and in fact what we've been able to do
is take organically derived materials
so very common abundant materials from
earth
and pressurize these in such a manner to
allow them to enter these exotic states
this is an unexpected system the
theorists in our community have all been
looking at very specific types of
systems
and this has come from out of nowhere
this is really the genius of my
colleague ranga diaz
in being able to not be
blinded by the bias in the community and
really have a fresh set of eyes and
looking at face space
below a certain critical temperature for
certain materials
electrons can actually start to see each
other not for physical space but for
energy space
and in fact electrons can start to begin
to pair with each other
over very very large distances but
they're actually coupled
in energy space and this coupling occurs
through motions periodic motions inside
the lattice
and it's this pair of electrons that you
form that now allow you to
demonstrate these beautiful and bizarre
quantum phenomena
the one way you could think about this
is that you have a pair of electrons
and the front one is traveling and takes
all the
all the hits and the back one gets to
sit
and basically have a completely
unaltered path
what we've really tried to do is take a
pure hydrogen framework
and exchange some of the hydrogens for
other larger elements
and as a way exert what we call a
chemical pressure on the system
this allows you to have a lower
mechanical pressure and really the aim
is to try and replace the mechanical
pressure completely with just the
chemical pressure
think of this way so if you have in a
room with 10
skinny people and you feel you know
there's an empty space and you're not
that squeeze
but you're going to replace these 10
people with the uh like in football
defensive
lineman like 300 pounds and now all of a
sudden you're getting squeezed
so instead of mechanically you're
pressing it you can actually chemically
do the same compression that has the
same uh properties
i can think of three different
directions that we can go if you can
really make a bigger quantity
at ambient pressure and ambient
temperature
if you take you know the electricity you
know transmission of electricity
from east coast to the west coast you
know you have a transmission line right
you have to send the current from one
place to another place
you have you need this transmission line
and the two days
when we use this transmission line we
lose about like 200
million megawatt per hour amount of
energy
if i convert that to in terms of dollars
it's
20 billion dollars so imagine you can
replace all these
lines superconduct the transmission line
with the superconducting wires
now that there is no you can transfer
electricity without any loss
one can envision in the future having
solar farms in the southwest of the
united states
and using a superconducting grid to send
energy to the northeast without any loss
or dissipation of energy
and then of course the the
transportation is the the next uh
big improvement that we can have with
this room private superconductor the
superconduct is not just a perfect
conductor
it has this property called magnetic
levitation so you can probably levitate
the
the trains and then you can have a
frictionless
tracks that you can travel faster than
what we are traveling uh now and then
that will
going to change the whole uh
transportation system
so the consumer electronics the
electronics that we use in right
nowadays is semiconducting materials
most of the you know your phone your
laptop you're holding now your cell
phone
and all these computers that we are
talking about the semiconductor world
but imagine you're going to build a
superconducting world
now everything is you have a
superconducting wire superconducting
circuits not just that then nowadays the
the biggest
you know the buzzword is quantum
computing quantum material right
so imagine that this will definitely
help us to even to have a room
temperatures and superconducting qubits
which you know directly going to apply
to this
quantum computing so this has really the
potential to
revolutionize the the whole world if you
can really make
one at ambient conditions
i think this kind of discoveries if i
can really excite young scientists young
students
who are coming to the lab and trying to
uh you know explore their curiosity
if this helped i would say that even
though we're going through this
pandemic you know this dark year of 2020
probably this will help them to really
motivate themselves not to give up
there are a lot more you can do than
what you can find and there's always
hope in this world yes there is rango
and thanks so much to you and ashkan and
your universities for making this
incredible discovery and for letting me
film it i found this
so inspirational and i hope you guys at
home did too
if you did make sure you press that like
button and share this video so that
others get to learn about it too
and please subscribe to my channel so
that you can catch the next one i'll see
you next time